-Yet another associate
of former President Trump
has been arrested.
This time,
it was the former chair
of his inaugural committee,
Tom Barrack,
who is accused of illegally
using his connections
and access to Trump to lobby on
behalf of a foreign government.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
There's a lot going on
in the world right now --
Delta variant, climate disaster,
wealth hoarding,
tax dodging, tech billionaires
who exploit their workers,
racing to space in cowboy hats
like Data,
playing sheriff on the holodeck.
Second Data ref in a week.
Is next generation
our new "MASH"?
But I'd like to start
with perhaps the most trivial
and least consequential
development in the news.
Disney unveiling its new
Joe Biden animatronic
for the Hall of Presidents.
Look at that!
Joe Biden was basically made
to be in the Hall of Presidents.
You can't tell the difference
between the real Biden
and the animatronic Biden.
In fact, given how much of
a wild card human Biden can be,
I'm betting his aides
would love
to have the animatronic
on standby for town halls.
"Oh, God. Oh, he's telling
the Corn Pops story again.
Bring in the robot.
Oh, phew.
Oh, now the robot's telling
the Corn Pops story.
Oh, wait. But, okay,
I can actually follow it.
I can follow
when the robot does it."
And I have to say
I enjoy the fact
that Disney made a realistic
Biden robot with
a presidential demeanor
and a normal
human facial expression,
as opposed to
the Trump animatronic,
which has the expression
of someone who just walked in
on their parents having sex.
I mean, lookit.
This looks like
one of the bodies
preserved in ash at Pompeii.
"Vesuvius is never gonna blow.
Yikes!"
Looks like Han Solo
frozen in Carbonite.
Also, who signed off
on making Franklin Pierce
look exactly like me?
You gave me one of
the worst presidents.
I grew up in New Hampshire,
so I actually know some stuff
about Franklin Pierce.
He was also from New Hampshire.
And nothing else.
I remember in fourth grade,
they told us that
New Hampshire news,
we lost our [bleep]
And then it was on
to James Buchanan.
Look, maybe one
of the reason --
[ Laughter ]
Guys, don't laugh
at the Easter eggs.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe one of the reasons
Trump's animatronic figure
looks so surprised
is it keeps finding out
more about
just how corrupt the campaign
and presidency
of the man he was based on were.
Every day, it seems like
we get new details
about alleged crimes involving
Trump's cabinet officials
or his business associates
or his friends.
Some of them are investigations
we didn't even know about.
It's like a game of Clue
where every answer is correct.
Was it Professor Plum in
the ballroom with the dagger?
It was.
How about Miss Scarlet in
the kitchen with the lead pipe?
Her, too.
Okay, and what about Rudy
in the billiard room
with the candlestick
to the nuts?
Yep. Every time.
For example,
we learned this week
that an inspector general found
that Trump Commerce Secretary
Wilbur Ross
lied to Congress
about the census
and presented those findings
to the Trump Justice Department.
But Trump's DOJ
declined to prosecute him.
And when Ross heard
he wasn't getting prosecuted,
I'm guessing he celebrated
by cracking open a beer
and a can of soup.
I mean, look at him.
That looks like the poster
for a movie called
"Retirement Frat."
"Wilbur, did you replace the
oxygen tanks with helium again?"
-I'll never tell, dude.
[ Laughter ]
That -- That is --
What you just saw
is 100% my fault.
And then there's Trump's
former campaign chairman
Paul Manafort.
A week ago, we found out
that a banker who arranged
millions in loans to Manafort
was found guilty
of trying to use those loans
to secure a job in the Trump
campaign and administration.
-It took a federal jury
less than two hours
to reach a guilty verdict
in the case
of former Federal Savings Bank
executive Stephen Calk.
-He was accused of
pushing risky loans through
for former Donald Trump
campaign manager Paul Manafort
in exchange for
a high-level position
in the administration.
Calk got Manafort $16 million
worth of loans from the bank,
despite concerns
from board members
over their high levels
of risk.
Manafort then recommended Calk
for an open undersecretary
of the Army position.
-Look, I'm sure this sort of
[bleep] happens all the time
in D.C.
and more people
should be prosecuted for it,
but, my God, Trump and his
cronies were so brazen about it.
The Trump operation was such
a toxic criminal enterprise
that even people who are
just tangentially related to him
are getting thrown in jail now.
At this point,
I wouldn't be surprised
if they get his Disney robot
for using a shell company
to dodge taxes.
Don't look surprised.
You know what you did.
Calk apparently got a job
on the Trump campaign
by loaning Manafort millions
despite his checkered
financial past.
And when Trump won, he actually
wrote down a list of jobs
he would want
in a Trump administration.
-Stephen Calk was convicted
for giving Paul Manafort
$16 million
in questionable bank loans
in 2016 and 2017.
After Calk's first multimillion
dollar loan to Manafort,
Manafort put him
on the Trump campaign's
Economic Advisory Council.
Prosecutors said Stephen Calk
repeatedly ignored
financial red flags
in Manafort's loan applications
because he desperately wanted
to be secretary of the Army
and that's how we could get it.
He listed, in ranked order,
his favored, quote,
"prospective roles" --
prospective roles
in the new administration.
His number-one choice
was secretary of the Army.
If not that, he'd take,
you know, secretary of commerce,
deputy secretary
of the Treasury,
18 preferred ambassadorships,
everything from the U.K.
to the Vatican to Singapore.
-I guess if you're the kind
of guy who ignores red flags,
you're also the kind of guy
who writes down a list
of the quos you would like
in return for your quids.
"Yeah, send a copy of this
to Manafort,
Trump, and, uh, uh, the FBI?
Is that dumb?"
Also, total aside here,
but if you're a corrupt banker
paying for a job
in the administration,
why would you want
secretary of the Army
over ambassador
to the Vatican?
I mean, the secretary of
the Army has actual stuff to do.
I'm pretty sure
the ambassador to the Vatican
just gets to hang out in Rome,
drinking Aperol spritzes,
and dodging Vespas
on cobblestone streets.
Every now and then, you run
into the Pope, and he says,
"I'ma from Argentina.
I don't-a talk-a like this."
Of course, Calk wasn't
the only Trump goon
to write down
incriminating material.
When prosecutors indicted
Trump Organization
CFO Allen Weisselberg
for alleged tax fraud
earlier this month,
it turned out they kept
internal spreadsheets
detailing the scheme.
For example,
according to the indictment,
Weisselberg caused
the Trump Corporation
to issue corporate checks
made payable to
a Trump Organization employee
who cashed the checks
and received cash.
The cash was given
to Weisselberg
for his personal use.
The Trump Corporation
booked this cash
as holiday entertainment
but maintained
internal spreadsheets
showing the cash to be part
of Weisselberg's
employee compensation.
The dead giveaway there is
that Trump would never pay
for holiday entertainment
on Christmas.
He would sit there
with Eric and Don Jr.
and watch the "Grinch" on TV.
"Why can't you idiots
be more like this guy?"
Then yesterday, we got news
about the arrest
of yet another longtime
Trump associate Tom Barrack,
who was an adviser
to Trump's campaign
and the chair
of his inaugural committee,
which incidentally
is also under investigation
unrelated
to these new charges.
-Tom Barrack, the chairman
of Trump's 2017
inaugural committee,
has been arrested
on a host of charges,
including illegally lobbying
for the United Arab Emirates,
obstructing justice,
and making false statements
to federal agents.
"The Washington Post" reports,
"Federal prosecutors say
Barrack capitalized
on his friendship with
and access to Trump
and other high-ranking
government officials
and his relationship
with U.S. journalists
to advance the policy goals
of a foreign government
without disclosing
their true alliances."
-So one of Trump's closest
confidants and advisers
was secretly using his access
and connection to Trump
to lobby the campaign
and the administration
as an unregistered agent
of a foreign government.
That means various
Trump associates
were either lobbying for
or connected to Ukraine,
Russia, Turkey, Qatar
and the UAE, among others.
That place was like the Epcot
world showcase of corruption.
This was supposed to be
the America First campaign,
the new working-class GOP.
Instead, it was all a bunch
of millionaire lobbyists,
bankers, consultants,
and private equity titans
working for foreign countries.
The so-called America First
campaign
was a bigger scam
than Subway tuna.
I'm not saying it's not tuna.
All I know is, last week,
I found a wishbone
in my foot-long
and then I pulled it apart
and wished for real tuna.
Now, we already knew
part of this story,
thanks to an investigation
by the House Oversight Committee
during the Trump presidency,
which found that Barrack
had submitted drafts of a 2016
America First energy speech
to the UAE for edits.
He took a speech with
"America First" in the title
and submitted it to a foreign
government for approval.
That's like finding out the cop
who did the Dare presentation
at your high school
snorted some fat rails off a
cafeteria tray to get hyped up.
"Whoo! Who's ready to learn
about how bad drugs are?
Wait. Uh, sorry. My friend Pablo
Escobar did a rewrite on that.
Who's ready to find out
how bad drugs aren't?"
And according to the indictment
released yesterday, Barrack,
a long-time Trump friend,
used that friendship
to get language inserted
into the then candidate's
energy speech in 2016
about the importance
of working with our Gulf allies
at the behest
of Emirati officials.
So, thanks to Barrack,
the UAE basically hired Trump
to do a cameo for them.
"UAE, it's Donald Trump,
and I hear you have
a birthday coming up."
But Barrack succeeded,
as you can see
from this clip
of the speech in 2016,
which was supposed to be about
American energy independence
and the so-called America First
energy policy.
Weirdly, there was a line
out of nowhere
where Trump seemed
to backtrack and say,
"Actually, we'll keep buying oil
from Gulf states like the UAE."
-We will become and stay
totally independent
of any need to import energy
from the OPEC cartel
or any nations hostile
to our interests --
anybody hostile
to our interests.
Believe me,
we don't deal with them.
We'll handle them just fine.
Just fine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, by the way, there are
plenty of them out there
that are hostile
to our interests.
At the same time,
we'll work with our Gulf allies
to develop a positive
energy relationship
as part of our
anti-terrorism strategy.
-He makes it so easy
for prosecutors.
You can literally see the moment
where he riffs off the cuff
and then goes back to the line
Barrack wrote for him.
He totally contradicts himself.
"Those Gulf states,
they hate us, don't they, folks?
Mark my words, we will never
work with them, ever.
Those Gulf states
can kiss my ass.
At the same time, we will
work with our Gulf allies
because they love us
and we love them.
And remember, they do
have a birthday Coming up."
The Trump campaign
and presidency
were one big
criminal enterprise,
a toxic cesspool of corruption
and self-enrichment,
and clearly, there's still so
much more we need to find out.
Among many other things,
it proves once again
that the new supposedly populist
working-class America First
Republican Party
is a total scam.
In reality, it was just a bunch
of wealthy oligarchs
conning voters
while they serve foreign
interests and rake in millions.
Every time we find out about yet
another Trump corruption scheme,
it's like taking a kick
right to the...
-Calk.
[ Laughter ]
-That one's not on me.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.